[Music]
a family day out
young and old flock into the Sri Lankan
president's house
seeing for themselves how this political
Dynasty has been living in luxury
a glimpse into the life of once the most
powerful person in the country
swarming into what was the country's
most exclusive gym
trying out equipment most could never
afford
nowhere was off limits
the beds are perfect place to pose
in the past six months people were
struggling in the queues people are in
the fuel queues people are in the gas
queues but now um people have hope this
is Colombo's newest tourist attraction
everybody wanting to snap their Memento
of this historic day
protest leaders who stormed the
president's house now tour guides
people not to steal
vowing that they will not leave until
the president and the Prime Minister
actually stepped down
we can't trust them since Independence
since photo 14 48 We Trust politicians
and we lost everything that we have so
we are not going to trust them we are
stay here until they resign
the police just look on making no
attempt to stop the crowds who have
taken over the heart of Colombo
for months Die Hard demonstrators
demanded their president take the fall
for the country's economic ruin
and then the anger exploded
infuriated by The Madness of a country
unable to afford to buy the most basic
supplies food medicine and fuel
this is what remains of the prime
minister's house
he said he is willing to resign once a
new government is formed
now his home is reduced to ashes
this appears to be the end of the
rajapaxes and then nearly 20-year long
grip on power they've brought the
country to its knees leaving it broke
and its people humiliated
[Music]
people power has replaced political
power
but the government is still negotiating
with the international monetary fund for
a three billion dollar bailout
[Music]
without that it's Euphoria may be
shortly
Nicole Johnston Sky News Sri Lanka